Thank you.
Hey, Melissa, it's you and me again.
Good to see you.
I don't know. This time I advertised more, but who knows?
This is pertinent to the last astrology space that I did that people seem to have some interest in, but, you know, I never know.
So we'll wait about, I'm going to wait about 10 minutes before I start to see if anyone else shows up.
I hate to make you wait.
So thank you for coming.
This is actually probably going to be pertinent to what we talk about.
So this is, this is good.
Actually, I, uh, hey, bark like a duck.
Great.
All right.
Um, this is, uh, this is very pertinent to, uh, some, the last astrology space I did and some questions people have asked me, uh, before I'm, I've kind of been looking into stuff and coming up with some, I don't know, some, uh, some ideas.
Uh, I'm going to be talking about, um, uh, it's dangerous to get into the Vedic astrology territory because then people will come out and, and want to, you know, hear a debate about what is the best system.
I'm going to try to circumvent that and just talk about one specific, um, one specific Vedic, um, transit this year, which is, um, Ketu.
Or Ketu, I'm not good with pronunciations, even in English, um, transiting through Magha Nakshrata.
Now it's not Magha, it's Magha with a G, H-A, um, M-A-G-H-A, but there is a similar sound there, but it's, um, I think it's a, it's a good, um, uh, bit of information for inner work, personal work, personal prediction for the events of the year.
And also like actionable, astrological slash remote viewing slash stuff, but I'm going to wait about 10 minutes.
Uh, I don't mean to inconvenience you guys, but, um, I just want to see if, uh, more people start.
I will say this, my, um, part of this, uh, transit of Ketu through Magha, uh, Nakshrata, the lunar mansion, right?
That's what we call them.
We call them, oh, he's gone.
All right.
He doesn't wait 10 minutes, which is fine.
So part of the, uh, transit through the lunar mansion is, um, dealing with ancestral trauma.
And like people talk a lot about trauma now or have, right.
But it's kind of cringe too, particularly like for us, you know, I think we've gone through the phase of like, um, when it was acceptable to hold our parents responsible for things that happened to us.
And then we can cringe to do it.
Um, and they look at it as, uh, ancestral, which I think is a good way of dealing with, because you're talking about like people, your great grandparents and your great, great grandparents.
And the stuff that's transmitted from generation to generation, it includes your parents, not as cringe, right?
It's not like saying we're going to focus on your parents.
Um, but it does include the parents.
So it's like a good way of talking about how the patterns that we develop from interacting with our parents still affect our lives without being completely cringe about it.
Um, I'm going to screw up the, the, um, I'm going to screw up the, uh, pronouncing the Vedic terms.
We have lunar mansions, um, in Western astrology, not, we don't use them very often.
Um, and they have, uh, their lunar mansions, of course, are not, right, not the same degrees as ours, the way they divided up.
Because of course we couldn't agree on that either.
Uh, their lunar mansion system is better.
Um, I, I, I, uh, I went to see my father earlier today and, um, we have a, uh, a Festivus, uh, situation going on.
So, uh, today was Festivus again, and I never know when it's going to be Festivus, but we just had a, uh, uh, uh, oh man, um, blowout fight.
So I was going to cancel again today.
I'm like, fuck it, I'm going to cancel this again because I'm not in the, the headspace.
But then it's apropos to the topic, to be completely honest.
So, um, it's apropos to the topic because the basic principle that they discuss is, um, this is a period of letting go of these past patterns and resentments.
Right.
And that leads through to the, um, if you're successful, leads through to the, um, to taking on a greater leadership position in, in the world, depending on how it affects your chart, um, would be where you would take this, this greater leadership.
If you're successful at, at, um, addressing this ancestral karmic stuff.
So yeah, I got this drop down just, oh, and I left, but you know, because I've been thinking about this stuff, I wasn't, I'm not resentful about it at all.
I'm like, this is, this is okay.
However, right as I was about to start this, I saw that Dan Waits of World Astrology Report, uh, has run yet another Astro RV, um, experiment without consulting Morgan and I, which is fine.
You don't own that type of idea, uh, but it's exactly what we were supposed to do, me and Intuitive Underground, and they dropped the ball on it.
And now I got to see this guy, uh, Dan, Dan Waits, who's very successful, um, as a astrology influencer and is very knowledgeable, but is not very experienced.
Uh, and, and certainly he, and he's, he's about five years into astrology, his, uh, remote viewing team are all about five years into remote viewing.
Uh, I've been, you know, a student of, or active in the astrology and astrology related disciplines for over 30 years.
Morgan has been a remote viewer for 15 years.
IU has been around for 15 years.
I mean, we, this is what we should have done.
So talk about like rehashing old stuff.
Like I, I saw that and I was just, oh, bullshit.
I can't believe he's doing this again, but hopefully it generated some good news, um, or some, not some good news.
Some, um, some Intel that we can use.
Um, this would be the perfect time to discuss that, but I just saw his video three minutes before I started this space.
So I haven't seen it yet.
I just saw that it exists.
So I can't share, um, I can't share that, that information.
Um, perhaps I'll run a space later tonight to share that information.
Um, if I have the energy after I, if, or, after I watch it, because it's, it's queuing into the crises that are happening right now.
And it's five remote viewers.
And like I said, they're decent.
He's decent.
It wouldn't be as good as if, you know, Morgan and I had done it, but I don't have control over other people.
Right.
And, um, it is what it is.
So it's just one of those things.
Um, all right.
Well, it's about 10 minutes past seven.
I thank you both for coming.
My phone won't really show me after a few minutes, if anyone joins or not.
Um, the last astrology one was pretty popular, but you know what?
I, I don't have an association to it.
One of the interesting things about the, um, this, uh, Maga Nakshatra transit is that it represents periods of isolation.
So, um, it represents, uh, working through ancestral karma and it represents, uh, isolation.
And what's interesting about this is, uh, from a Western standpoint, right?
The big astrological event of this year is Saturn conjunct, uh, Neptune.
And it's, in my estimation, the biggest astrological event in a hundred years, more, right?
I mean, this is a transformation of civilization.
And I, I made the spaces last year.
I've been posting about it for years now, trying to get people to pay attention to the fact that the technical, um, the technical meaning of Saturn conjunct Neptune at zero degrees Aries is the collapse of global civilization.
It's not the extinction of global civilization, it's, but it is a collapse of global civilization, right?
And so we were able to look at that and say, um, you know, last summer you would see the precursor events.
And then after the 21st of February, you would see the events start to take place where you would see this collapse build.
So Neptune rules, rules oil, for instance.
Okay.
So one of the things you could predict going back a couple of years, or you could actually predict it a hundred years ago, if you had the astrology, right?
Is that, uh, during this period of global collapse, there would be a global collapse in the oil infrastructure.
And that would end up creating this global crisis.
It's not just the oil infrastructure, right?
It's the, one of the spaces I made about this earlier this year, or at the end of last year is a karmic deep impact.
It's a massive karmic crisis.
It's a massive crisis coming through the collective unconscious.
It's an oil related crisis, and it's a natural disaster related crisis.
And these combined together from an astrological standpoint are the, um, the main events.
Now it's at zero degrees Aries also includes war.
It's war related to these topics.
Right?
Um, as a matter of fact, zero, Aries in general, Neptune and Aries in general are crusades.
And they also, and I've made spaces on, on that.
So I'm not going to perseverate too much, but it also always includes Russia.
Um, so all those pieces came together pretty much exactly the way one would predict.
And it's unfolding right now.
People are still in strong denial about how serious the situation is, particularly in the U.S.
People feel that, as we always do, that we are immune to the effects of events in the rest of the world.
Well, it's going to unfold over the next couple of years.
Um, well, again, cause I've talked about this before without spending too much time talking about it.
The last oil shipments from Saudi Arabia going to JP Morgan arrive on the 15th of April.
So after that, although we don't get most of our oil from Saudi Arabia, we do get some of our oil from Saudi Arabia.
So after that, you're going to see a shortage and that shortage will be, even in the U.S., there'll be a shortage.
And that shortage will probably, because it's, it's smaller than in other countries, right?
It'll probably be dealt with through the price mechanism.
It could be dealt with through rationing.
Um, it will be close to the level of demand destruction, ultimately, that we experienced during the, uh, during COVID.
It'll be much, much greater in other areas of the world.
But to start off with, if the war doesn't spread to our energy infrastructure, you know, we are looking at lockdown type levels of movement.
Whether, again, it could be through rationing or it could just be through the price mechanism, kicking gas up to $12 a gallon for everyone, right?
Okay, so that's what Western astrology said was the big event of this year.
So what does Vedic astrology say is the big event of this year?
Well, in, in, in Vedic or, um, Jyotish, I don't know how they pronounce it, but that's traditionally it was, it's called Jyotish.
It's, uh, J-Y-O-T-I-S-H astrology.
And, um, there's a lot of argument about where the various forms of astrology came from.
I am a strong proponent of the idea that, uh, Vedic astrology, uh, was brought to India by the Greeks when they invaded Northern India under Alexander the Great.
And for a long time, there wasn't any, um, evidence of that physical evidence.
It was just reason, but they've now found the physical evidence.
They've found ancient copies of, um, of, uh, Greek texts on astrology.
And it makes sense because what most people don't understand is the Greeks ruled a large chunk of India for hundreds of years.
And even after that, the, um, Greco-Bactrian kingdom in what is now Pakistan and Afghanistan was there for even longer.
So it wasn't as far, like there was a strong influence and the, the powerful, wealthy, cosmopolitan, glamorous civilizations in that part of the world at that time were ruled by Greeks.
And so that information sort of trickled out.
And a lot of the differences between Vedic astrology and Western astrology are the, um, the fact that the information was sort of, um, absorbed, right?
Without the history.
So some context was lost during the absorption of the information.
And that's where the Vedic idea that the, the stars are causing the events as opposed to correlating with the events, right?
Um, the Western concept of astrology going back originally to the Hermetic period, um, is, you know, so above, so below, uh, you know, the stars are a map of, of human consciousness.
They're not a causative force shaping events.
Uh, the Vedic, um, uh, Jyotish Vedic astrology, uh, you know, has, has developed a, a strong belief that these, uh,
heavenly bodies are, uh, heavenly bodies are, are active forces shaping our lives.
They also use, um, in, an updated, um, zodiac, basically updated based on our, our movement through the galaxy.
That makes sense to people, uh, at first until they recognize that since astrology originally, and still with me, is a map of human consciousness.
Um, the movement of the planet through the galaxy doesn't mean, make any difference.
Um, the profession, the procession of the equinoxes does not make any difference to astrological interpretations.
You're actually using the map and should use the map that was used at the very beginning when the system was developed, because you're basically using it as a, as a tool for, for viewing regular cycles that exist inside human beings, not, not in the galaxy around us.
Anyhow, I'm all wired up today, but I'm doing better than, oh, my last space was dog shit.
Thank God Melissa was here, because otherwise, uh, it would just be me, like, rambling into the void.
Uh, I was frustrated.
Okay, so, um, the K2, which for us is the south node.
The lunar nodes are, in Vedic astrology, they're planets.
They're unseen, invisible planets.
And there are people, even in Western society, who are strong components of Vedic astrology, who believe that they, they are out there.
Invisible planets are out there.
Um, those of us with, like, modern Western astrology, we, you know, they're points, um, that are useful, uh, astrologically, as if there were planets there.
But there are no planets there, from, in, in our, in our belief system.
The points themselves are the points that eclipses happen on as the sun and moon move around.
Um, and when they, when they form eclipses, they do so at set points in the sky.
And that's the, the north and south nodes.
The usefulness, the utility of the north and south nodes in both systems is based around karma and evolution.
Um, the north node is, is where we're going in the future.
In Western astrology, the north node is, is highlighted as being the important node.
The north node is seen as, as your mission in this life, and, and also what will happen in your next life.
So, where your north node is, might be an area where you will eventually work, or where you will eventually develop an interest.
Not at the beginning of your life, but later on.
It's also, if you have a situation where you have, like, let's say you had a relationship, or almost had a relationship.
And it was like, everything was clicking.
And it wasn't just chemistry, but it felt sort of almost faded.
But some obstacle kept you from being with that person.
Right, you've developed karma with that person.
And, and the north node in the charts can show you if you will have a relationship with that person in the next life, or another life.
From an evolutionary astrological perspective, we use the south node to show us who had relationships with whom in previous incarnations.
Or previous dreams, from my perspective, and what those relationships were.
So, you can look at it and say, that's what will bring people together in this life, the karma of those past relationships.
So, you can look at two charts, and from the locations of their south node, the one in question, Ketu, you can see these two people were father and child in a past life.
Or these two people had a passionate love affair, but didn't marry in a past life.
And so, they're in this world right now, in this dream, or sequence, or simulation, or whatever it is.
And they come together to work out that karma.
Ketu, and its role, is much more prominent in Eastern thought.
Right?
So, Vedic philosophy is based around the principle, or one of the things it's based around, is the principle that, you know, we're trying to escape, we're trying to ascend.
That's where this ascension is the Western word for the Vedic principle of moksha.
We're trying to fulfill our karma, and escape this level of existence, and move up to the next level.
And the belief is, there are a number of levels above ours, but perhaps none below ours, but definitely a number above ours.
So, we want to free ourselves from our obligation to each other that goes from life to life, so that we can then bounce, get out of here.
Ketu shows us what that, or the lunar south node, shows us what that obligation is, what that karma is, that needs to be worked through in order to get out of here, in order to achieve moksha, liberation from this level of reality.
This particular transit, the reason this is so important for them, the reason they, you know, aren't looking at Saturn conjunct Neptune, even though, you know, the whole world is, is acting out that transit right now.
Is because this is because this is a particular period where it is possible to work through ancestral karma.
It is possible to, to like, just clean house and get rid of a lot of that stuff we came into the world with.
And depending on where it is in the chart, it'll show you what particular areas of your life you're going to work through that karma.
Or you'll have the opportunity to work through that karma.
This is an, every 18 point something year process, not quite 19, not quite 18, somewhere in between, the nodes transit the, the zodiac.
And so, uh, the last time that, um, Ketu entered, uh, Maga Nakshirata was, uh, 2007, the summer of 2007, which was a very faithful period for me.
So I, if you look at my chart specifically, um, my Vedic chart, and you look at the lunar mansions, then you can see that for me, the karma I'm supposed to work through,
the ancestral karma we're supposed to work through is, it relates to relationship with my parents.
Everyone, it would a little bit, but with me, it's specific.
For other people, the relationship would be in different areas of their lives.
So I, I, I'm the one who got the cringe relationship, um, karma, uh, past life karma, right?
So, um, during this period, which began on the 29th of March, um, the Western lunar mansions, by the way, um, divide the Ketu,
uh, sorry, divide the Maga Nakshirata in two pieces.
So there are 28, um, lunar mansions in the West.
There are 27 lunar mansions in Vedic.
I don't, I've never seen anything of value from the lunar mansions in the West.
So I have to give it to the Vedic people on this.
And my explanation for this is that Western astrology is very based on how the world affects us and how we try to affect the world.
And Eastern, right?
Eastern, I, I, I, I'm repeating myself, but what they're focused on is how to, uh, stop the world from affecting us and how to stop ourselves from affecting the world in such a way that we create a future obligation for ourselves.
So what Ketu is doing in Maga Nakshirata, as far as I understand, I posted a video in the comments.
This girl is very good, woman, woman is very good.
Um, I would recommend following her.
I don't recommend dishing Western astrology and embracing Vedic astrology for a number of reasons.
I think that there are a couple of useful parts of Vedic astrology to use, but, but we live in a Western world mostly, right?
Um, but for the karmic and spiritual development, I think that specifically the Eastern, um, techniques revolving, involving the lunar nodes, uh, Rahu and Ketu, um, are, are superior, are useful.
Whereas ours don't seem to be very useful or as useful.
Um, so this began on the 29th of March and, uh, what we're seeing now, and we will see going forward, according to the Vedic astrologers that I've listened to.
And I, my exposure to Vedic astrology is listening to YouTube videos and then going and checking it online to make sure I understand it.
I'm not trained as a Vedic astrologer, right?
So, um, I'm just giving you my best understanding.
Uh, it's going to last about nine months and it's a period where you're going to be exposed to, um, well, first the world will be a lot of, uh, people who are in leadership and I want to get anyone excited about this.
Uh, people who are in leadership positions and they achieve those leadership positions through corruption or they're corrupt in those leadership positions.
Uh, and this stretches from like a global level to a personal level.
Um, so it could be your job, it could be the coffee shop on the corner, it could be in your family, but people who have achieved leadership positions through corrupt practices, um, those individuals to a large extent will be leaving those positions during this period.
Um, so it could be, uh, the personal benefits that we experience in life that are resulting or that result from other individuals, corrupt practices.
Uh, those will also be leaving our lives.
So in 2007, 2008, when this was happening last, right.
Uh, at the end of that was a spike, a period of inflation that led to the, the great, um, recession.
Now it's the great recession is not going to be, is not going to hold the candle to the crisis that we have this year and next, but it's sort of a way of demonstrating how collectively there was a change in leadership, uh, both in the U S around the globe, probably in our personal lives and our jobs, et cetera.
There was a bit, there was a big theme and the, um, the end of benefits from corrupt practices.
One way a person could look at that would be economic trouble in general, because, you know, economic boom times are often periods of inflation and economic boom times are periods of corrupt behavior.
Inflation itself is the strongest corollary, um, I think in the world for, for corruption and corrupt behavior.
Um, and, uh, it has an effect and it's, it's, it's, we all recognize during periods of inflation that, um, that doing things that benefit us in the future make less sense than doing things that benefit us in the present.
And generally speaking, corrupt behavior is behavior that benefits us in the present without thinking about the future, which is exactly what this, um, Nakshatra is about this transit of K2 through, um, Maga Nakshatra.
Now, um, like what's going on with Epstein is the perfect example of this.
Um, but the, I'm going to say this cause I'm, I'm, I believe in being a good citizen and I don't believe in being political.
Um, so I don't want it to come across as being political.
I don't believe in being political as a prognosticator.
Um, in general, the crisis that's going to happen to the world and I'm not celebrating it.
It's terrible.
It's going to be really terrible, but it's what's happening now.
It's overtaking countries with this, like this fuel issue.
And then it's going to be shortages of food.
It's going to be shortages of medicine and it's going to be political turmoil, right?
That that is the result of this, of corrupt behavior, right?
You could say it's the result of allowing Iran to behave corruptly for a long period of time.
You could say it's the result of allowing another nation or other nations in the Middle East to
behave corruptly for a long time.
You could say it's the result of, of us behaving corruptly or our government behaving corruptly.
You could also say that since we benefit from that corrupt behavior, we, to an extent are
party to it on a karmic level.
So that itself, right?
The rug is going to get pulled out from under us in the way that we benefit from what could
be corrupt behavior.
So you're seeing that happen right now, uh, just as we could explain it through the transit
of Saturn conjunct Neptune.
I'm like, I have a checklist.
Well, not a checklist.
It's like a rough, um, so, uh, Maga Nakashatra or Nakashatra.
Is ruled by Regulus.
This is something we've also talked about and something that UFO X is trying to figure out.
And we're dealing with like the next couple of weeks, the predictions of Chris Bledsoe.
He's a UFO alleged non-human intelligence contactee who like many non-human intelligence contactees
was left with a set of predictions.
He has a pseudo religious, well, pseudo is a value judgment, right?
He has a religious veneer around him and, and there's a religious veneer around his experience
and his predictions.
But he has long predicted, uh, that new information would enter the world around Easter of 2026.
Now, like most people who make predictions, his predictions continue to change, but that is
the basic prediction.
Um, he has recently started talking about, uh, or did recently, as we got closer to this date,
start talking about October of this year.
I think he switched back to April now that events that he had predicted are coming to pass, which includes a war in Iran
and, uh, and, in more, um, UFO sightings related to the war with Iran orb sightings.
Mostly, um, those things are now happening.
So I think he might be back on the Easter train, but, uh, Regulus itself, his prediction was that
when Regulus, uh, rises, um, on the horizon between the paws of the Sphinx, uh, these events
would happen.
And of course, um, if anyone studies this, they know that Regulus does not rise in, um, Regulus
rises in the autumn, not, uh, in the spring.
And so that created some cognitive dissonance because he had been given this prediction, supposedly
by a non-human intelligence.
Remote viewers have looked into it, seem to agree he did have an experience.
So without judging them, I think he did have an experience, whether it was, whether there's
a certain level of deception in those experiences, that's a subject for another space.
The reason this is apropos here is that, uh, K2, right?
Which is red, I believe.
And the reason K2 is red is that the Vedic image of K2 is a headless monk.
And I, they draw them, they draw the monk as, as beheaded because Rahu is the head and K2
is the body in their, uh, their system, their, their symbol, their symbolic system for explaining,
um, Vedic astrology.
And, uh, Magha Nakshatra is ruled by Regulus.
So even though that's not exactly what Bledsoe said, it's a lot closer to what he said than his
interpretation.
And so I think that's, that's notable.
Um, what was I going to say here?
I'm, I'm looking at my, yes.
The other thing I think is notable.
We did some spaces about the Kali Yuga last year and the theory that the Kali Yuga was
ending in 2025, but the process of the end would take quite some time.
And one of the things that, uh, both the individuals responsible for the prediction, the Kali Yuga
would begin to end last year, but also esoteric teachers over the last couple hundred years,
uh, who've talked about that process in 2025, 2026.
Um, the period prior to the very end of the Kali Yuga, the way they describe it, it's a period
where angels and demons exist together in the same world, often in the same body.
So if you think about like, um, a political figure, if you think about a celebrity who's,
um, loved by the masses is very charitable, but also you find out they did like horrible,
corrupt things, you know, they're in the Epstein files.
That would be the, the ideal example for what one would expect in the last days of the Kali Yuga.
Following that, you would see a division, right?
Because the next stage is for, um, angels and demons to exist in different worlds, no longer
exist in the same worlds in the same body.
So that division would obviously have to begin with the ex, with exposing corruption.
So that's something that is part of Hindu mythology.
And I don't want to, I get accused of appropriating every time I talk about, uh, someone else's
mythology, someone else's, um, prophecies.
I have studied, two years of study of comparative eschatology.
So if anyone could talk about it, it should be me, but I don't want to provoke negativity in people
because I'm, you know, I'm not someone in their eyes who should be talking about the prophecies
of these other people.
I will say that this, what we're experiencing, this, this, these events related to the astrology,
both Western and Vedic are very similar to experience, events described in the early stages of Hindu
prophecy, um, related to this period of time.
So, um, what I'm saying is this, this is in line with the next stage of the end of the Kali
Yuga and the beginning of the next, we're in a period in between, right?
So, uh, some other similarities between the two, between Saturn conjunct Neptune and K2 in the
Maga-Naksharata is that, uh, K2 in the Maga-Naksharata strips away illusion.
That's what Saturn-Neptune is all about, right?
Saturn either solidifies illusions into reality or it just dispels illusions, almost like a,
a magic, uh, formula, you know, in a game.
Um, this is a part of dispelling false identities, both on a personal and a larger level, right?
Like a societal level and relationships that no longer serve us.
So illusionary things.
So Neptune in Pisces is like the, like with the last 14 years is the, is like a giant party
for illusionary things, like ideas that aren't real, um, definitions that aren't real, um,
sort of crazy behavior where a bunch of money is thrown at, um, I don't want to, I don't
want to put judgments here, but a bunch of money is thrown at, um, at groups who were perceived
to be marginalized, um, mass movements of people, things like that happen when Neptune is in,
um, Pisces.
So that changes when Neptune enters, um, Aries.
In the same way, when K2 enters the Maga-Naksharata, that stuff is also dispelled, right?
And those relationships that, uh, have developed that are no longer serving us, everything that's
based on corruption is exposed and then it disappears.
Uh, the karma is broken.
Now, in Vedic, uh, yoga, Vedic, uh, astrological, symbolic legend, I don't know how to explain
the story, the narrative, right?
The ancestors are called, um, oh God, Petries, with a P.
They're the, they're, they're like luminous, collective human ancestors and it's, it's them
who are running the show or trying to run the show.
Like, we're not supposed to think, we're not supposed to overthink things, we're not supposed
to plan, we're supposed to just follow the Petrie's lead and during this period of time.
Now, that is, that is relevant to the intuitive underground material because the Petries, in
my opinion, refer to the, the, the, the sleepers, refer to the, the people who are the base for
the, for the reality overlay, for the matrix, for the simulation.
And I like this, this girl here who I linked in, um, you know, she refers to right, right
off the bat, she refers to this as a simulation, which anyone who really studies Hinduism knows
that Hinduism absolutely believes this is a simulation, right?
Like long before the word was ever coined, that's the basic principle of Hindu belief.
So, um, when they say that the Petries are guiding us to dispel collective and family
karma so that we don't get stuck here, right?
Our, my perspective would be, um, that that is a reference to like the, the original inhabitants,
right?
The original people who went into the reality overlay, um, that Maga Naksharada is considered
to be Ketu's throne.
So that's where this, this idea of achieving leadership is concerned.
Like this, um, as, um, Ketu begins the transit through Maga Naksharada, right?
Like we start, we, we are confronted with this ancestral karma that, that manifests differently
in each of our lives, depending on our chart that we have to dispel.
They want us to work through this ancestral karma.
The gift that we get, the reward that we get for that, if we're successful is a greater leadership
position.
So, uh, serving and following ends up, you know, is the key to leading and a great ability or
power to change the world.
Now that would depend on, right?
Like obviously, uh, if, if you're an important person, a celebrity or a, uh, a billionaire,
right?
That's the amount of power you're going to have is much greater than that of an average person.
But in our own little world, in, in, in our environment, in our family, in our job, in our
community, right?
If the, the individuals who use this time to, to dispel the collective karma, the way that
we're intended to the ancestral karma will achieve a greater position in, in that, whatever area
in, in, in, in your family life and your work life, whatever area that you're working to
dispel that karma, uh, because this is ruled by regulus, this nakshadur, regulus is, is
signified by greatness, but you have to be free of resentment.
So I think the way she talked about it was free of revenge and grudges.
Like you can't want to get people right.
You can't be so filled with, I mean, when grudges and resentments to me, like it's an
interchangeable term, but perhaps other people define them differently.
Um, I understand the feeling of wanting to get revenge.
I, that's my greatest vice.
Wrath is my greatest vice.
Um, I, I, I'm not a great, I want to help people.
I want to help humanity.
I want to help everyone around me.
But when people, uh, knowing that still wrong me, I feel very wrathful and revengeful to
them.
So this is like an important point for me, a point period of time for me.
Um, I think that revenge and the desire or sorry, and resentment and the desire to achieve
revenge are very similar.
Um, when you look at this, she wasn't saying this is what I'm saying.
When you look at, um, Vedic texts, you'll find like, if you go back to like what Krishna
said, and again, I'm not, I'm not the greatest expert.
I'm not trying to appropriate.
I'm just repeating what I've learned.
Uh, it wasn't so much the actions as the attachment to the actions, right?
Like that, that create these karmic bonds that we have to, like if you have, hypothetically,
if you have zero attachment to your action, then you don't receive at least the same karma,
if any karma from that action, right?
You're, um, you're being moved by something else.
Uh, however, when you're attached to that, when you want to get revenge, when you, when
you are consumed by resentment, uh, then your actions, or even just the, and this is why
I say resentment as opposed to grudges is the important distinction, right?
Your resentment and your attempts to, to get revenge.
Hi, um, oh my God, what's her name?
Uh, demonic.
Uh, she is a, um, Vedic or joy to assure, I can't pronounce things, uh, astrologers.
She's an expert in this.
Um, when you're filled with resentment or, um, the desire to get revenge, right?
Like that in itself, even if you don't succeed, um, generates what in the East would be called
karmic, um, bonds from our perspective, right?
Uh, when your soul, your spirit is trying to leave this world, um, there are desires, um,
and, and obligations that, that hold you here, right?
Like some people, um, they want to come back cause they, they're, they're all sexed up,
right?
They want to come back because, uh, you know, um, sexuality calls them or some people, I mean,
maybe myself, man, I hope to God that I don't, I don't leave this life and then come back
specifically cause I'm, you know, I just want to eat and that would be horrible and humiliating.
I guess it's possible though.
Uh, but hopefully I'll have overcome that by then.
Right.
So those are some of the reasons or, or, or, or, or people want to harm other people, right?
And, and getting back at all the people, believe it or not, is one of the things that traps
people here.
The desire to return to a world that is fundamentally unpleasant, uh, to them in, in order to have
the satisfaction of, of harming somebody because they wronged you, which that wasn't true, but
it is, I mean, you think about it just in our lives, right?
Like you don't have to go and look at it in this grand, like reincarnation and life to life.
You can just look at this.
How many times in life is a person ready to move on to something else, but then they turn
around and they get themselves trapped because they have to like get the last word or they
have to like, just hurt the person a little bit more.
This is a very real phenomenon.
And it's something that I, um, I had, you know, like I said, I, it was really lucky for
me that I wound up going to visit my father today and having him turn today into Festivus
because it gave me, like, I wasn't planning on having Festivus today.
Um, and, you know, having him hear his grievances and his accusations and, and eventually getting
kicked out of his house an hour later after, you know, after going through over and over
with him that this happens to us at least three times a year.
And it has since I was eight years old.
Um, but this time I was able to sit back, especially thinking about this.
Like I knew I was going to do this space and I'm like, wow, okay.
I still got pissed off.
I still yelled a little bit.
Um, cause you know, we hit my, my buttons, but I'm not resentful about it.
Well, I was able to say, wow, look, this guy has no control.
His resentments control him.
He doesn't control his resentments.
He is being overwhelmed by the power of resentment.
And thinking about all the areas of his life, he is overwhelmed by the power of resentment.
He's, he's in his late seventies and he's still overwhelmed by that, all these resentments.
And I mean, it's not just looking at him and saying, well, I don't want to be like that.
I mean, I, I'm, I, the chance of me getting to 77 are very slim.
Um, but I don't even want to be like that next year.
Right.
So that was a great example, uh, for me of exactly what I had heard when I was listening
to this, these videos, particularly this, this, uh, Sophia's video, you know, it's like,
yeah, this is exactly what, what she was talking about.
Um, so I'm not saying that dealing with that, with the relationship with my father is, is
going to, uh, lead me to some sort of benefit.
I'm saying like, you know, it certainly will clear away one obstacle to me moving forward
in some area of my life, if not every area, right.
To no longer have, um, the resentment holding me to, to those encounters.
I wish that he didn't have to feel that resentment because it's really amazing to observe somebody
who's completely out of control.
Right.
And I'm sure we've all had that experience where you're talking to someone and like their
feelings, their belief there, whether it's a collective ideology, let's get social thing,
something they saw on the news or something they feel powerful about.
They just can't see anything from anyone else's perspective.
Some people are much worse with that than others.
And they get worked up and it's, you can't, you can't explain anything.
You can't derail.
You can't for the, for the, for love or money, you can't stop them from repeating the same
things or saying the same things, accusations or, or, um, grievances or whatever it is.
You know, sometimes it could be love, right?
Like sometimes a person is so obsessively in love that they can't stop idolizing the other
person.
They can't stop.
Um, right.
It's, it's stalkerish if they're not with them.
And if they are with them, it's obsessive.
Right.
And so it's, it's really interesting to see someone who's that out of control because it
says like, when, when do I feel that way?
When am I that out of control?
And what I took from it, not to, you know, cause I want to get back to the subject instead
of just, I'm just using myself as an example.
I'm not trying to perseverate on myself, right?
I said, like, if I've done all this work over these years through these, oh, numerous encounters
with my father, um, and I've really reached the point where I no longer feel resentment
towards him, even after getting blasted and accused and blamed.
And I said, there are other relationships in my life where I do feel resentment, right?
I'm not able to overcome it.
Probably way too many of them.
And so I said, well, what have I done?
To, to, to be able to detach from resenting him, right?
Like, what do I recognize in him that I'm, that I'm not, that I haven't yet recognized
in everyone else that, that I have resentments towards this man is not in control of his,
he is acting out a role, right?
It's a script written for him by his ancestors behavior or written for him by the people created
the simulation, whatever it is.
Like, this man is, has reverted into NPC mode.
And, um, you know, what, is that not the same for the other people that I resent?
Like, are they not, right?
The things that I used to resent about him aren't things he did.
They were things he did, but that's, but it wasn't just because it was what he is, right?
Like, sometimes you think somebody is, is, is being awful, um, or offensive or aggressive
as a choice.
And in a sense, it is a choice, but in another sense, it's not a choice because it's, it's
what they are, right?
A good example is like when you're young and guys fight over women.
And it's funny, I'm not saying that, you know, I'm not being heteronormative, whatever sis
is, whatever, I'm not doing that.
What I'm saying is like this specific instance, I'm sure it plays out in other, in other types
of relationships, but you know, when someone is like really jealous and aggressive, and it's
like that role takes over them and they're basically animalistic in their behavior.
That, that same thing happens to people in, in other areas of their life and later in life.
There are times when transpersonal forces, I don't want to use the term hijack or possess
because then people, the few people who look at this video, we'll start talking about aliens
and God only knows demons or whatever their perspective is, right?
But the transpersonal force, the archetype subsumes the individual and the individual doesn't
have a choice in what they're doing.
And so because we know that at certain points in our lives, or even certain points during the
day, we're going to be encountering other people that we're not encountering as a one-to-one,
right?
It's not encountering as another individual, we're encountering a force, right?
We're, we're, we're not encountering someone who's in love, we're, we're encountering someone
who is love, right?
We're not encountering somebody who's, who's, um, who, who's choosing to be a bully or aggressive
or demeaning or, or scheming.
We're encountering people like that is a, a part of human nature.
There's a part of, of, of biology that, and at that moment, that is, this is what they
are, right?
There's not a value judgment saying that's all they are.
Like that person is, is just a schemer and they're always a schemer.
But in that moment it is.
And because of that, they lose the, the power to choose in that moment.
And that's what we think about.
That's what like therapy is all about, right?
Or, or, um, spiritual practices to a large degree, right?
Is to develop the ability to detach from the moment enough that we do have a choice at that
point in the moment.
But in our natural state, we don't at some times when we're subsumed by these archetypal
forces, right?
Unless you're like a, a, a meditator or a very introspective person.
Like there are times when it just washes over you and you can observe that happening in others
who aren't introspective, who aren't meditative, like all the time.
So I want to take that and I want to look at the other relationship in my life.
And I want to achieve the same level of serenity.
I want to say like, look, that wasn't something they were doing out of a choice in order to
harm me.
That was something that they are in that moment.
I think that's in line with the message of this, um, nakshatra.
And that's why I bring it up.
I know it's like, I'm perseverating on my own life and talking about relations with my parents
and all this fucking crazy, ridiculous, cringe shit, but it does fit the, the actual transit.
I think on a level we're all doing that, right?
Um, it's going to come up in everyone's life.
And I think we have to look at it that way.
We have to, you know, sometimes we're relating to people as individuals.
Sometimes we're relating to people as, as, as, uh, NPCs, as, as transpersonal forces.
And we can't be, um, resentful because that ties us to the world, right?
Like that person has no control of what they're doing.
So what do you want to be resentful and then lose control and then come back to like, relive
this same story over and over through dream after dream, right?
Through life after life or whatever it is.
So that's what this, this transit allows one to do.
Uh, K K two is going to allow us to stop doing that.
When they say like, get rid of ancestral karma, it means stop living out.
Collective individual family oriented patterns of interacting with each other that aren't individual
choice that aren't as the result of a meditative, um, observer related, uh, perspective, right?
Like it's stop those visceral reactions that we have interactions and stop the cycle of
those relationships.
And if you can do that, then, right.
That not only helps you, um, work towards ascension, but that helps you work towards authority.
So people ask me all the time.
I mean, you know, I'm not a celebrity is this isn't a commercial.
People ask me all the time, like, but when we do these spaces around subjects like the archons
and the reality overlay, people ask me, well, what can we do?
Right.
Like, what can we do to try to get out of this situation?
And this is what it is, um, with the remote viewers that I've worked with a lot of times
they get fixed on the unfairness of it.
They get really transfixed by the corruptness of the process of us being trapped in this reality.
And so it's difficult for them to properly analyze, uh, and that's my opinion properly.
Uh, it's difficult for them to objectively analyze the possible solution related data in the perception
set.
They, they, they, they struggle with that.
Um, and they want to talk about how it's, it's not fair.
So we've talked about like, it's about, you know, there are, there are vices that we all have
that tie us here and whether it's fear or not, that we're here, whether we chose to be here
or not, whether we were misguided or misled to be here or not, as long as we participate in
those vices, right?
We're reinforcing the ties that bind us into this system.
So for instance, um, uh, you know, I'm not judging people who are wealthy.
What I'm saying is, is that if you are a very wealthy person and you say, well, I want to,
I want to get out of this reality overlay, how do I achieve moksha, uh, when my life is done?
I don't think you can.
That's just the reality.
You know, I'd say the first thing you do is, is, is sell what you have and give the
money to the poor.
That's not a popular thing to say in 2026, right?
We want everything to be consumer item, including liberation from reality, right?
It's like, how do I purchase that?
Like, what's the incantation?
And I don't think it works that way.
I really think you have to address like the seven main vices that people have.
We've talked about that before, but we didn't talk about interpersonal karma because that's
something that definitely gets reported by these remote viewers is that, you know, you
are challenged when you try to leave to return and complete the karma.
If you have completed a large amount of your karma, if you've cleansed this ancestral karma, if
you, if you've approached your life like that, as, as people did in early Christianity, as
people do in, uh, renunciates in Hinduism and, uh, as, as Buddhists try to do, et cetera, then
the case that can be made against you is obviously like a much thinner case, right?
Like go back and, and deal with your karma.
Like, well, I have dealt with the karma.
It's that type of thing.
So this is like really a period of time.
The next nine months is a period of time where it's possible to, um, I think to make big gains.
This is, this is my interpretation of this, right?
To make big game gains in, in preparing to get out of here.
If that is what one wants to do.
So I think it's, it's, it's very important.
Um, part of that is surrendering inherited roles though, right?
Like the, the, the illusions, the false identities, the relationship no longer serving us and inherited
roles.
That's where the isolating aspects of this transit comes, comes into play.
So Saturn conjunct Neptune doesn't necessarily predict individual isolation unless it, um, unless
it affects one's chart in a specific way.
Uh, this, uh, uh, K2 in the Makai Naksharada definitely says like, if you want to, you know,
if you want to progress, if you want to move on to the next level for you, whatever that
is, right?
Like you've got to like stop benefiting from corruption and you got to, are you going to
be isolated because you have to let go of relationships that aren't serving you?
Cause that's also a form of karma.
Like, even if the relationship is pleasant, if it's not helping you achieve spiritual liberation,
then the ties that you're developing with that person are, uh, you know, are holding you back
more than they're helping you forward.
So over the next nine months, people who, who want to make headway in, in clearing out ancestral
karma are going to be necessarily isolating themselves to a certain degree, uh, and preparing
to step into, or in the process, right.
Of stepping into leadership roles, I, I don't know if it occurs.
Like I'm not familiar enough with Vedic astrology to say like, this is something they predict
will happen at the very end of the transit.
Like, it seems to me like this is something that's like ongoing process.
Like you are stripping away the ties that are holding you back and you're naturally then
going to move into that position of, of greater authority.
That's would be how I would interpret it.
Right.
But this isn't, this isn't, um, something that happens as the result of planning.
This is something that happens as the result of, of action in other areas of your life.
So it's an indirect, it's a second order effect.
Another thing that everyone should, you know, may, okay.
So not everyone, but people should be prepared for dreams and visions.
Uh, Neptune, right, rules, dreams and visions.
So Neptune, uh, Saturn conjunct Neptune can definitely, um, indicate, um, dreams and visions.
Uh, but, um, Ketu in, in, uh, Maga, Naqshara does, uh, particularly for some people and specifically
dreams and visions of, of ancestors.
So it's possible that people might have, um, dreams of their, their ancestors that never
met ancestral forces or like the ancestral archetype, but also people that you've known.
And I don't know if you guys have had this experience, but I have certainly been having
more dreams about people that I knew early in my life recently.
I haven't had dreams of my grandparents yet, but I anticipate that might be something that
will happen.
So that's definitely something to look out for.
Like parents dreams about your parents, if they passed dreams about your grandparents dreams
about people that you knew when you were younger dreams about the archetype of ancestral forces.
And some people could have visions.
I don't know.
Um, I never know how to approach the subject of people having visions because it means so
many different things, right?
Like some people imagine something in their mind and they call it a vision and some people
actually see visions, but I don't understand it because I don't, uh, I have dreams, but I
don't, I don't see visions.
Um, but if you are somebody who sees visions, this is a period where you are likely to see
visions related to ancestors.
Um, so yeah, that's the, the big difference between.
The two, like the biggest transit of the year for the Vedic and the biggest transit of the
century, if not millennium for the Western, right?
Like very similar themes.
And that's often how it works out.
Like we come at things from different like starting points, but we often converge together
in predictions and in experience.
Um, and I, I, I want, I'm going to spend more time, um, learning about the Nakshatra system.
Um, just because I want to be able to offer, um, I want to be able to offer insight about
this development to people, um, as a, as a form of, um, as a, um, a type of, uh, consultation,
right?
From my perspective.
Um, so it wouldn't be entirely a Vedic perspective.
So that's what I'm going to be working on.
I recommend subscribing to Sophia cause she's, she seems like she really knows what she's
talking about.
Um, she wouldn't have the exact same.
Uh, like the way, because of the IU material and the things that we believe, I'm obviously
going to interpret things a little bit differently, right?
Um, from a less mythopoetic perspective and more of, um, uh, collective unconscious techno
synchronicity related perspective, but it's going to be roughly the same, right?
So, um, that, that's something that I'm going to talk more about in the future.
I want to, uh, I want to see Dan's video and I might come back in an hour and see if anyone
is looking for a space to break down Dan's videos, prediction of, um, what the, the row
viewers predictions of, of what the next step in the developing crisis is.
So, um, it's just the three of us.
Well, there's one anonymous listener who welcome an honest listener.
Uh, you are also welcome to come back.
Like, I don't expect everyone to shape their schedule.
I mean, it's, it's fucking amazing.
Melissa is always here and Barkley deck.
You're, you're very often here.
Um, and I, I really appreciate, uh, it.
So, um, it, it means a lot to me, uh, but I don't expect everyone to shape their schedule.
Oh, we're requested.
Hold on, dude.
All right.
Let's go for it.
Nope.
You're still a listener, but I did approve you.
There we go.
Oh, perfect.
How you doing, man?
Figure out how to work this thing sooner.
No, you, it's me.
It's me.
You're a thousand times better than I am.
Um, well, I appreciate the space.
Um, it's really interesting stuff.
I don't know much about the Vedic aspect of astrology.
Like you, I'm more interested in Western.
Mm-hmm.
Um, I'm wondering if, uh, what sort of, uh, effect are, this is happening in, uh, Aries
and the early, uh, aspects of Aries.
I'm wondering how the, our houses in the natal chart might be affected.
Okay.
How do we look at it through that lens?
Saturn, um, Saturn conjunct Neptune is happening in early Aries and that would relate to what
the way you would be affected would be if, um, it forms, uh, uh, you know, mostly it would
be people, there's a conjunction or an opposition or a square, right?
Like, so 90 degrees, 180 degrees, zero degrees.
If you have a planet there, you would look at that planet and then you would look at the
rulership of that planet.
So you would find what house, um, Aries is on the cusp of in your chart.
So we look at the chart and say, what house Aries is at the beginning of, and that would
be where the event happens, right?
So, um, in my chart, that's the second house.
So the event itself is related to possessions and money and, uh, and the face, the mouth and
eating values, um, then you would look at the planet or points, if it, if it aspects your
ascendant, if it aspects your MC or, um, if it aspects a planet and then you look at where
the planet ruled.
So if, um, if you had the sun at zero degrees Aries, then, um, in the second house, no, I'm
I'm getting too complicated.
I'm getting too abstract here without a chart to show you.
So basically the event happens in the house that, that Saturn is conjunct Neptune in.
And it's like something that happens there that's happening to the planet, right?
So, um, if it's third house related, it's transportation related, but the planet might be in the sixth
house, which means, uh, health.
So if you have, uh, um, uh, if you have a, um, an astrological transit in your third house,
that, um, that is a square to something, a planet in your sixth house, you can have a car accident
that then puts you in the hospital or, uh, causes you to miss work.
Right.
And then the outcome is, is it gets complicated because it's a three-step, it's a, it's an
algorithm that you would look at the, um, the house in your chart that's ruled by Leo.
And that's where the outcome would be in this case, it would be the seventh house.
So you'd say like, uh, I'm not saying this is the case for anyone, but I'm saying like hypothetically
one, you know, you could have a car accident that happened in your, um, a car accident that
happened that causes you to lose your job.
And that causes you to lose your relationship.
So that, that would be a three-step interpretation process, uh, because of how Saturn and Neptune
are working together right now, there would be more like the price of gas is so high that
I can't drive anymore because I can't drive anymore.
I can't go into work or I work at home.
And because of that attention, um, it, it harms my relationship.
So that would be how it would be from a Western perspective.
What's going on with Ketu in, um, Maga Naxtrata, Maga Naxtrata is in, uh, it's in sidereal
Leo, which means it's in tropical cancer and some.
Mostly tropical cancer.
So it's at the early part of sidereal Leo, which means it's in the middle of cancer.
It, if you have a planet, you're particularly, um, it would be the same thing.
Like if you have a planet in that area, um, the, the, the lunar mansion itself, then that,
uh, this event would be something that's very important to your life.
Like one of the reasons that you're here, but as opposed to a Western astrological transit,
like this is going to affect you personally, even if you don't have a planet, um, aspected.
Right.
So, uh, because this is, um, this is related to your karma.
It's not, um, related to forces outside yourself.
I mean, it is a force, but it's not the same force as the transpersonal forces, the collective
forces that affect you via transits to, to planets.
This is like, um, not something that's happening now.
It's something that happened in the past that's affecting you.
So like a Western transit interpretation is something that's happening now, right?
That's having an effect on your life.
K2 is something that happened in your past lives or when you were younger, um, or when
you lived in a different part of the country or something.
Right.
So it's just a different way of, of, of looking at it.
And so it doesn't have to aspect a planet.
You're looking at where that is.
So you need a Vedic chart.
I'm sorry, I'm going to get up cause I'm going to be a fucking cat dormant again.
All right.
So you, you need a Vedic chart.
You need to look for where K2 is, which is the South node.
And, um, Vedic uses whole house, or at least in this interpretation, you use whole house
signs.
So you would either start with your ascendant sign and then count out to where Leo is.
So my ascendant sign in a Vedic chart is Sagittarius.
And, oh, well, because we're not using Leo, right?
Okay.
So it's just fucking crazy.
Trying to put the two together, uh, for me is kind of crazy.
So, um, basically my ascendant is in, um, Sagittarius and a Vedic chart.
Maga, nakshrata is in my seventh house.
Um, let me count it out here.
Uh, Capricorn, uh, Aquarius, Pisces, Aries, Taurus, Gemini.
Um, yeah, um, seventh house, uh, related to, um, fuck, I'm screwing this up, dude.
Okay.
So, uh, it's ninth house from Sagittarius.
Not, um, because I'm, I'm trying to, I know I sound like an idiot right now, but it's because
I'm, I'm so used to working with Western charts that I'm trying to translate it in my mind.
And I keep slipping up and mixing the two up.
So basically from my ascendant, Maga, nakshrata is in the ninth house.
Um, but because this is a lunar mansion system, um, what you're really looking for, uh, is your,
um, lunar sign, right?
So mine is, uh, is in Leo, but it's, it's, um, it's in Leo, uh, in the Western.
So it's in Cancer in the Vedic, but it's not in Maga, nakshrata.
Um, I end up being, uh, second, second house from the lunar system, um, lunar mansion system,
lunar astrology.
Uh, so that's how you, you start from your moon sign and, uh, count to Leo.
And that's what house it is.
You start from your ascendant and count to, um, uh, uh,
Yeah, I would do it.
I can show you, I, I don't know if I can articulate it, right?
It's, it's, um, it's wherever the, uh, uh, Maga, nakshrata is in your, um, in your Vedic chart.
Uh, that's the area that you would look at for, um, uh,
where you're going to experience the past life karma.
So, um, I don't know.
Do you know what your ascendant is?
Um, Western.
I assume you do.
Western.
Okay.
That's fine.
What, what, what, what, what, did you just give me the degree of your ascendant?
You have to tell me the rest of the chart.
I don't want your secrets, but just what's the degree inside?
Six degrees, uh, Scorpio.
Okay.
So six degrees Scorpio is Libra.
So, uh, Libra, right?
So, um,
so the 11th house would be, uh, I have to look at it.
It's either 10th or 11th house.
You should look at it because I don't want to screw that up.
It's either the 10th or 11th house would be, uh, from your ascendant.
And then, uh, Leo, uh, Virgo Libra would be the third house.
Mostly the third house would be the most prominent.
Um, so like, uh, third house themes involving, uh, past life karma would, uh,
relate strongly to siblings, cousins, school friends, um, trips, driving, which is interesting.
And that's from the Western perspective.
The Vedic would probably have other things attached to it because they have,
the houses have slightly different meanings.
Of course we can't agree on anything.
Right.
But that's where you would start to see the karma.
It's basically, it is the, it is the South node in the Western chart, right?
Yeah.
But it's, uh, interpreted through the Vedic, right?
So when you, when you go, um, it's a sign off, right?
Not, not for everyone.
Right.
It's 20 something degrees, but for most of us, it's one sign off.
So if you're a Scorpio, uh, six degrees, you're a Libra in the Vedic system.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
And you use whole house signs and you work forward from that.
Now, like I said, I, I want to offer this to everyone, but I'm not at the point where
I, I can, because as you have just heard, um, I cannot, uh, I could do it if, um, like
if I was working with you, I could do it because I would be prepared when I talk to you.
Right.
But off the cuff, if we had a screen with a chart on it, yes.
But off the cuff, it's difficult for me to make the transition from one chart to the, the other.
Um, especially since, right.
It's like 20 degrees.
It's not a whole sign off, right?
It can't be, nothing can be simple.
And Western lunar mansions.
I think I mentioned this at the very beginning, uh, West, we have 28 lunar mansions in the
West.
Uh, they have 27, uh, nakshatras.
So we can't even have the same number.
Right.
So it's even our, our, um, the Amaga nakshatra is both the 10th and 11th lunar mansion in
the Western system.
So it's just like everything is, is mixed up, but it's mixed up in like the most complicated
possible way.
However, with these lunar mansions, like in the Western system, I can tell you, like I can
look at your chart and a wife or husband or whatever, whatever it was.
Right.
And I could say like, did you know each other in a past life and how I can look at a Western
chart and tell that using the lunar nodes, but this type of detailed information about
a karma past life, we don't have it, um, or at least not easily accessible.
So that's why I think the nakshatra system and what they're talking about is, is very important,
even if it's, if it's difficult, because this is going to give us, um, right.
This is going to give us a way to focus on what type of, um, what's the best way to process
ancestral karma for the purpose of individual liberation during this period of time.
So for you, it's going to be the, the third and you're going to check it's either the 10th
or 11th, um, houses, um, 10th is obviously your profession, um, and your, your public image.
And, um, this isn't the Vita is the father and the father, I think.
Um, but again, they, they mix up all the definitions of the houses.
So I would have to check that as well, or, uh, groups, the 11th house, um, organizations,
whatever.
I mean, you should, I think because of my experience, right.
And I'm just basing it on my personal experience.
Like already, um, my chart predicts ancestral karma coming up related to, uh, family possessions
that may be based on, you know, corruption or, you know, may have been from the profiting
from corruption and the relationship with my father, right?
So we're four days in five days in, and I already have had a crisis with my, with my father.
The advantage of, and that's why I recommend her video is, um, the VDIC system, they have
remedies for everything, specific remedies, like actions you can take to lessen the, um, the
impact, uh, of the transit or to facilitate the benefit from the, the transit.
So for instance, dealing with the second house, right.
Um, one should feed people, make food for people or bring food to the homeless or right at a,
at certain regular frequency.
It could be once a week.
It could be once a month.
This is what she says.
And I think it makes sense.
You know, the ninth is working through resentments that you have for your father.
So that's perfect there.
Um, for me, right.
Uh, so that those specific remedies are going to vary.
Like we're not big on remedies in Western astrology.
We haven't been for a long time.
Um, I'm very critical of VDIC remedies because I don't like the fact that they sell gemstones
and amulets and things like that.
I think that it's a way that some people take advantage of others.
And there may be a strong benefit from it.
I don't know.
I've never, I don't have any evidence, any research to base it on, but I, it's definitely,
um, an opportunity to hustle people.
Right.
And so my concern is the opportunity to hustle people.
Um, because I'm not convinced with the benefit, but perhaps there is like if a gemstone is
inexpensive and someone wants to try it, that's fine.
But telling a poor person, you know, they have, you have this horrible malefic transit and
it's going to afflict you and you need to buy a, you need to buy a gemstone from me or this,
this bangle, this bracelet, or all horrible things are going to happen to you.
That's the type of thing that happens.
It doesn't happen with every, be it an astrologer, obviously.
Right.
But it does happen with some.
And if somebody doesn't have any money, like that's, that's really bad.
That's, it's a terrible thing.
But it's a future forecasting group does that remote viewers.
And they, they opened up a store and they sell like crystals and shit that are supposed
to shield you from EMF radiation and things like that.
And they're in crypto.
Yeah.
And well, in crypto, of course they get the crypto too.
Right.
But like they have, they brag about the number of millionaires they've made that survivorship
bias, but perhaps, perhaps they have.
Right.
But they have a ton of poor people who spend $60 a month to listen to them as a form of like
insurance that they can hopefully get some information in case something terrible is going
to happen.
And they're selling them fucking gemstones.
I don't mean to disparage them because they're really good, but the one guy, whenever I watch
his videos, I feel like he's selling me a timeshare in Florida.
Is that Dick?
Yeah.
The guy with the muscle.
Dude.
They're good astrologers.
I mean, they're not astrologers.
I'm astrologer.
They're good remote viewers.
They're not the best, to be honest with you.
They're hit or miss, right?
If you gave me a choice, you say, do you want to hire Dan and Morgan, or do you want to hire
Dick and Daz?
I would choose Dan and Morgan.
Dick and Daz, hit or miss, sometimes they might be the best in the world.
Other times, they just bomb.
I know you didn't see the video, but are you familiar with the group that Dan Waits worked
with today?
Oh, yeah.
With the second house?
Yeah.
So they're new.
Okay.
So they're all five years in.
So here's the thing.
So is Dan, right?
Dan is five years into astrology.
Josh Maitland is five years into remote viewing.
So Morgan is actually the one who brought this up to me, and I wasn't on it, but he has some
really tremendous insights sometimes.
He said, you know, when you're five years in, you think you know a lot more than you do.
You've like mastered the technical information.
You read, probably if you have a passion, you probably read everything about the subject.
You've started to see some good results.
So you overestimate the effect that a lack of experience can have on your ability to analyze
things.
And that's 100% the case with Dan in astrology.
And I believe it's the same with Josh and his team in remote viewing.
They're very good remote viewers.
Not, you know, no better than Morgan or Dan.
Not probably the best remote viewer in my estimation, to be completely honest with you.
I hate to say this because I think the guys in future forecasting group aren't good people.
I don't think they're good remote viewers.
I don't think they're good people.
Ed Reardon is probably the best remote viewer in the public eye, from my perspective.
Although sometimes he really bombs.
But he's really, like on a good day, I don't think you ever would choose anyone over Ed Reardon.
Josh and his group, they're probably, like, ability-wise, they're probably someone who could work with
Morgan or Dan.
But experience-wise, they're not.
And that does make a difference when it comes to analyzing or when it comes to, like, sometimes
writing out the targeting.
But yeah, like, I don't know how much they charge.
But would I hire them?
Yes.
I would hire Josh Maitland to work for me as a remote viewer.
I would.
But given a choice between Josh and Morgan, there wouldn't be any choice.
There'd be Morgan every day.
So I do listen to them.
I've listened to their, they put out some, like, human news.
They put, you know, like, next month predictions.
They're not very good at it.
Future forecasting and farsight are much better at that.
But that takes time to master that.
And people miss a lot, right, when they're targeting the next month.
I'm eager to see, like, I'm going to put weight to their conclusion in this video.
Like, I'm going to take it seriously.
And I'm going to, I'm going to utilize the information as constructively as I can.
I don't think that it would be like if Morgan, Dan, and I, if Morgan had, if we lived in an ideal universe, and, you know, Morgan had followed through with what I believe was going to happen.
If you put me and I, if you put me and I, you together, I'm, I'm guaranteed we'd be better.
But, you know, that's, that's hypothetical.
That's an imaginary thing.
It's something that didn't happen.
Well, I definitely want to hear your take on, on the world astrology video today.
Because one of the, at least a couple of them actually kind of resonated with something.
I think, I think it was Dan, someone in one of your spaces talking about a tower and confusion at a tower as being a significant event.
And also one of Ed Reardon's recent, had a recent one about a speaker, like a leader kind of thrust in place.
So it's, it seems to be resonating with at least two other remote viewing sessions.
I'm going to tell you the first thing that comes into my mind, and I'm going to tell you it now, because we're not doing the, right.
We're not doing a space on that subject right now, so I don't have to parse my words because I haven't seen it, right.
But there's, there have been a number of, it has been suggested in, in online rumors that Los Angeles is being specifically targeted.
And there is a tower in Los Angeles that has been mentioned as, as a potential.
The reason that comes to mind is that Dan and Morgan's material, they saw a tower on the West Coast.
So the fact that the rumor now is that there is a potential issue with a building in Los Angeles down the line, that, like, that's what I would, that would be my first reaction.
But I haven't seen the material, so I don't know.
But I am going to see the material, and I, and I will come back on tonight and talk about it if you want to talk about it.
And I will do that at, at 9.30 if you're available, Eastern Time.
I just want to give myself time to, uh, no, hold on.
You know what, I can't do it at 9.30.
How about, uh, 9.10?
And I'll, I'll go listen to it now, and I'll come back at 9.10.
And then I'll have time to talk about it, then feed the cats.
Yeah, go on.
Unfortunately, I got to, um, cook me due for tomorrow.
But, um, if it's a little later, I'll certainly pop on.
I'll keep an eye out one way or another.
I definitely want to hear your, your take on it.
Yeah.
Yeah, so the thing is, I got to, I got to feed these cats, and, uh, I do that at 10 o'clock.
So I try to clear the deck by two, by 10 o'clock.
And also, um, you know, some spaces I get more people.
Recently, I've, I've just been getting my, you know, you guys are great, right?
But, uh, uh, a small crowd.
Um, but I, I, there are times when I don't, if I do it early, I don't get anyone.
If I do it late, I don't get anyone.
And that's fine.
It just, it just doesn't make any sense, right?
Also, holiday weekends, when people are probably not usually.
Sure, sure.
I mean, you know, that goes either way.
Like, holiday weekends for, for me would be, you know, a small crowd.
But I bet you tomorrow, um, tomorrow evening, we'll see, like, one space run by Logan or Red Panda, if he's allowed to run spaces again.
And, um, like, for UFOX people, and there'll be a lot of people there.
So it's, you know, holidays, people want to spend time together.
They want to do, like, group stuff, right?
So you're going to look for the, it's, like, entertainment, and it's, like, a group feeling.
So you're going to look for the space with everyone there and tune into that one, as opposed to a smaller space any day.
Um, but yeah, if anyone, um, and Melissa, of course, you can always do what you need to do.
But if anyone is here in, uh, 40 minutes, I will, um, I'll, I'll run a 40-minute space talking about what I think about the data.
And you can listen later, right?
You don't have to, uh, be here to listen to what I report.
Um, you can just listen to it whenever you're ready.
You can also just watch their video.
But I, I want to, like, just give my own take on it if anyone is, is interested.
Because remote viewers don't, like you were talking about, you know, Morgan and Dan talked about a tower.
They talked about, so remote viewers don't pay any attention to each other's session data for a number of reasons.
Some of them good and some of them, uh, bogus.
Uh, so if you asked, um, if you were to sit, like, Courtney or Dick or, uh, Daz, whatever, down and ask them to, um, discuss the differences between the data of the different groups, they, they wouldn't, they wouldn't be able to do it.
They don't, they don't spend that much time paying attention to each other's session material.
So that's what I do bring to the table with that, is that I do have a, you know, a broad knowledge of what seems to be going on with each group.
So that's, I'm able to draw the correlations if they exist.
Um, do you have anything else, uh, did I really butcher that, that, um, Lunar Mansion thing?
Or did you get pretty much what I was saying?
No, no, I got what you were saying, uh, generally speaking, anyway.
I don't know, I'll have to do my own chart in, um, in the genetic astrology and see what's going on there.
Yeah, and I don't, um, yeah, no, like, if it's just, uh, I'm sure you can figure it out yourself.
But if you have, like, once you do the chart, if you, if you want me to tell you what is where, then, then that's like three minutes, just send me a thing.
And I'll just tell you, yeah, that's the 10th, that's the 11th that you're, you're looking at.
It wouldn't be like, um, a session, right?
There wouldn't be like a consultation.
It would just be, uh, like a three minute question.
I'm always open to that.
Right.
I did have one question about my chart, but I'll shoot you a DM later.
Yeah, sure.
I mean, like I said, if it's a quick question, I can answer it.
No problem without, without there being any like onus or obligation or anything.
It's when, you know, you put in hours of work to prepare to, to read a chart.
And, and so at that point, like if someone wants like a full consultation and you say, okay, well, you know, this is, this is how much I would do that for.
But if it's like a simple question, then, you know, it's not going to take any time.
It's fine.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right.
Um, unless you have anything else or Melissa would like to say anything, uh, or our anonymous listener, I'm going to end the space.
It takes about 15 seconds.
Thank you both, uh, for coming and then the anonymous listener.
Thank you for coming as well.
And, uh, I am going to go watch the video and, uh, Oh, and if I don't see you guys happy Easter or whatever holiday, but Easter is the one I celebrate.
So happy Easter, although I, all right, have a good night.